so we're gonna make this
quick because uh we were about to film a
reaction to uh supernatural for patreon
and then this news just started blowing
up our notifications
hollywood reporters talking about it
variety's talking about it
grace randolph tweeted about it there's
a whole bunch of people who have been
talking about because apparently warner
brothers put up a trailer for wonder
woman 1984
had it unlisted in that trailer it has
this graphic right here on screen
in theaters and on hbo max uh december
25th
christmas day they really are up in the
game on competing here
and as i was editing the video hbo max
released the trailer it's official it's
actually happening
holy moly i mean you got soul coming out
on disney plus that very day same offer
i think where
it's not no extra cost for subscribers
mulan they tried that with disney plus
mulan you had to pay extra money for it
in order to watch it even if you already
had a disney plus subscription
this here hbo max wanting to boost their
numbers
putting wonder woman out here there's a
lot to factor in when it comes to this
new story warner brothers hasn't said
anything about it because it sounds like
a mistake occurred
or maybe they did that intentionally as
they're like let's just see what
what people think about this yeah and
then we'll go from there let's
let's see if people are forward or
against it i could absolutely see them
doing that kind of trial
there are certain parts of the world
where hbo max is not yet available so it
makes sense to put it in theaters over
there
some parts of the world might not have
the pandemic as
heavily or as serious right now putting
it out in the theaters over there
that does make sense and also with the
fact of how hbo max is becoming the
go-to landing page for when it comes to
dc
related content whether they have a dc
category there
i watched all of harley quinn that's how
i watch all the doom patrol and
they have all the movies going on there
they got the snyder cut coming out
supposedly maybe in just a few months
early into 2021
so this could be a good train for them
to keep on going you know you start with
wonder woman 1984 as a big temple movie
putting on hbo max and then you go into
snyder cut a little bit later now the
question comes down to like the personal
biases here there are some people who
really want this to come out on hbo max
or just on video on demand
and they're i mean gosh that's the
movie's an expensive ass film and
getting an hbo mac subscription is
nowhere near as expensive as doing a
video on demand
or buying a ticket to the theaters i
mean just doing a rental on like
amazon or something like that is more
money than getting an hbo max
subscription on top of that too if you
know you could just do a free trial on
hbo max for that day and then cancel it
if you wanted to that
that's the part of me that was going
well if you're trying to get more
subscribers i i get the idea
of you get them to sign up for hbo max
so that way they watch wonder woman 1984
and maybe they browse around the catalog
that we have
and they go you know what i'm going to
keep hbo max that's kind of how i got
suckered into it and that's how i have
it
and i'm having the same contemplation
right now with youtube tv doing my free
trial and i'm like maybe i do want to
pay
60 dollars
for linear television on youtube
the bias cited me doesn't want to
experience this movie for the first time
on hbo max or on at home like this is
something where
i really want to experience this the
first time in the movie theaters if
that's the case
you know all right i guess i'll i'll
watch it
on home if it's not available at the
theater within driving distances to me
i mean i'm super duper torn on this
because yeah it is the kind of movie and
especially it is of a franchise that is
one of the main ones you want to see in
a theater so
yeah on one hand i am sitting here going
yeah small screen is not the way
even on christmas day it's more special
blah blah blah but you know it's
not exactly the way i would want to see
it but then again it truly makes me
wonder because
as we're seeing right now it's really
hard to predict what this pandemic will
do
part of me you know sympathizes with the
studio in the sense that you can't just
hold these things forever
and i wonder what's gonna happen off the
back of this decision because again
mulan you could argue is one of those
canary and coal mine moments where it's
like okay
that damn broke and now what other
movies are gonna come out but i feel
like wonder woman 84 is an
even more mega iteration of that
conundrum because now
this is like their a tier movie
they have coming out for the new year
and now what else is going to come out
on hbo max on the heels of that or any
other streamers like you know i could
see this being very easily a damn break
moment that has a huge
impact going forward on just what it
means to be playing in a theater at all
when they should open
so i think this could be huge though
this could do great numbers
because it's one of the 1984 it's a
sequel like the discussion around mulan
yes while that is technically part of
some weird franchise
in a certain extent if it's part of the
disney mulan franchise
disney remakes franchise yeah but it's
not a
follow-up you know at the end of the day
it was like the first time
doing this for mulan whereas this is a
part two
it's not this like for me i'm still
gonna opt black widow should just wait
i'm still there yeah because
we've been waiting a long time for
blackwood to have a solo movie so i'm
still opting to wait for that for a part
two though for a for a really big
well-received film
this could rake in some serious
viewership
though it could reagan some serious
viewership but i'm also like
okay is this why though why release this
now like why why not wait is it to
satisfy fans
is it the business strategy of trying to
get more people to go to hbo max to
compete within the streaming wars
because
reportedly hbo max's numbers are nowhere
near the level they've wanted it to be
at
to me that seems like the main reason to
do it
yeah is to get more people to hbo max
but like i said
you could just get a free trial yeah you
know and
banking that gamble on a free trialable
moment does seem
like a very calculated risk because
someone would have had to have brought
that up
i mean you could do a free trial and
then what you could be really smart
about doing is if you put
the snyder cut out it's not going to
happen but if you put it out in january
that way you're like oh damn that's the
key i have to stay
pledged to hate me yeah i mean that
could be the way to do it
it really could be the way to do it hey
and that's the thing is they've had all
this time
over the past several months to come up
with strategies like these or to at
least i would imagine
entertain these ideas that probably back
then they were like we'll never come to
that
and and now we might yeah now wonder
woman
in 1984 supposedly costs around like 200
million which is a safe assumption right
and then on the marketing fees and all
that it does cost a lot of money i
imagine this move will not make
theater owners very happy because i know
there's a lot of theaters right now who
are
obviously obvious goes out saying
they're struggling yeah and i think
they're like when this is over
we can really recuperate a lot of money
there's a lot of big movies
waiting to be released you know
we're just gonna let it all slow down
when the world opens like this is
creating a certain type of business
chaos with a lot of
you know some discussions that come out
in the in the trades and all that but
then a lot though i'm sure
most of us are not hearing about you
know the thing with streaming service is
like you can share an account
you can also um have multiple people in
one room
together so if you want to recuperate
all the money you invested into one room
1984
the money that you're like well we'll
make bank at the theaters no problem get
15 of your friends together you've
covered your subscriptions
is there a way yes that's i mean is
there a collected dollar
how much have they factored this out to
the point of is it all just to get
people to go to hbo max because
there's a big possibility that of course
i i don't doubt that it's going to get
a significant amount of viewership yeah
but i'm using the term viewership
and not money because exactly there's a
way to really cheat the system that
i think everyone knows about yeah and i
mean i don't know
anywhere near as much about how
streaming
money works as opposed to tickets but it
only makes sense to me that with a movie
ticket you got
the movie the money going through one
movies
like one chain through that movie and
whoever the money goes to whereas
a subscription fee there's a library and
they're not only going to watch wonder
woman so yeah
and how do they calculate that stuff
where does the how does your viewership
affect where your subscription money
goes and yeah how do we
tie that back to wonder woman or is it
just the sort of thing where it's like
well
we picked up a million more subscribers
so success
and then there's this other part of the
argument that's been being brought up
that i'm not sure how much i
i i feel for like i get it i i respect
it i'm not sure if my feelings are as
strong about it as others are when it
comes to this part the pandemic's been
getting pretty crazy
again like it's been getting worse
especially where we live like the
numbers have skyrocketed
it's because we keep testing yeah like
they've gotten really bad
and there's that concern though that you
put this out on streaming that more
people are going to gather together
the form gathering like well we were
talking about ways to cheat the system
that more people would gather
and then that just makes it all worse
when you know there's been a lot of talk
about having this holiday season to make
some sacrifices about not
spending as much time with loved ones or
you know not really having those social
gatherings that encouraging this is a
bad thing
i'm like well seoul's already coming out
and if there was one movie for families
to gather around it would have been
disney plus's soul and hbo max does kind
of need to compete right yeah i'm just
like well whoever was going to gather
was already going to gather i i
i don't know i don't know what it's like
i don't know what the mentality is of
most people
to be like you know what i wasn't going
to but i could watch wonder woman on
christmas
let's do it you know everyone let's get
everyone together you know i i don't
party i don't know what the mentality is
there
maybe uh that is the case where most
people are like you know what i wasn't
going to spend christmas with anyone but
now i'm going to
i guess the time watching it and can't
really fight this anymore yeah well yeah
because it's either the certainty of
streaming or the uncertainty of
everything else all right guys well do
you
care this is coming out do you want it
to come out on video on demand hbo max
do you are you
do you want them to just wait for the
theaters leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification
bell hit the like button last but not
least
rosa parra the wonder woman of our
patreon page now rosa
as tough as 2020 has been you've been
kicking a lot of booty throughout the
year and i'm proud of all the hard work
you've been putting in
and i do want to say to you and your
family that i hope you guys have a happy
thanksgiving
there's one thing i'm grateful for this
year for sure it's you
you've been a treasure in our lives and
i love the hell out of you so a big part
of my thanksgiving will be in
celebration for thanking you
for being in our lives for such a long
time and i hope
that when you're gathered with the
family you have an awesome dinner you
guys pig out
and that you guys don't get too nasty
with one another because you know these
family gatherings can be
yeah awkward and uncomfortable except
when you're there to light up the room
rosa and to bring your insight and
expertise because
hey i mean you know your movies you're
active within your community you're a
role model to us all
heck yeah rosa yeah love you